Julia trying to leak out and get another
assist saying having a terrific season
making the all-star team for the first
time he's averaging 20 points 12
rebounds to get there
relax Steph Curry Gibson look back at
the benches
the cover have that Steve Kerr the other
day played his team a loop of turnovers
just to emphasize the point and if it
changed things for a game okay this is
highly critical eye Looney
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah the Warriors shot well from three a
part of that was our transition defense
was very poor but he said it's not just
the 30 like the one Kevin Durant a pitch
here's curry followed by T curry got the
step sets it up for Thompson yes
Thompson catch up shoot yes his curry
had to kouya ahead of the field but
changed his mind on giving it up while
locked away and see curry blocking off
the Alita not allowing him to get to the
ball toss
that's what you have to do if you
Minnesota you're still only 11 down and
you've given up three point of this they
can continue to give up three point as
it fast breaks a bottle by Durant here
come the Warriors one hop pass gluteus
stop back tapped handle by a huge
following in China and it's been very
touching for him he had a great
experience this summer there and it's
Minnesota you still owe me 11 down and
you've given up three point of this baby
continue to give up three-pointers in
fast breaks you can turn around here
within striking distance Chris how
quickly the Warriors get it it's a
six-point game with 420 remaining as we
got around top 7 to 3 yes
[Music]
who's gonna be like man we were so close
no you weren't that's the trick that's
the booze doll to play it against Garden
State you think you were in it because
you scored more points than you usually
do
[Applause]